hey everybody welcome to or welcome back
to the into the impossible podcast i am
your fearful host
dr brian keating although i will be
slightly less fearful
after reviewing this wonderful
conversation i had with
uh world renowned world famous youtube
sensation evan carmichael
uh who has about a dozen youtube
channels
uh millions of subscribers uh all over
the world but what's so interesting to
me is that he's very humble
he's extremely humble he's a uh he's a
disciplined person a very successful
person and he doesn't really seem to
believe his own you know pr
uh he has an amazing team that helps him
out
but i think what really signified to me
that you
in the audience who's used to thinking
about scientific uh discoveries uh life
on venus
and the mysteries of the multiverse will
appreciate is
how to overcome the natural fears that
we have even those of you i won't
include myself humbly
what i will say those of you in the
audience who are exceptionally high for
you know performers
and how you can do that and still in his
way
he feels incredibly uh unsuccessful in
some sense and it's just amazing to me
the humility that he has
after the success he has now we didn't
have a chance to get really into the
book but some of his tips on
what you should do when you feel scared
to give a scientific talk to
speak to the to the press to speak to uh
your students
uh friends communicate what you do in
the sciences outside
the sciences were really refreshing
exceptionally
actionable and i really enjoyed it he's
a very humble guy stuck around
afterwards just to
to chat even though he's got you know a
full-fledged
day and studio ahead of him he uh he's
seeking knowledge he's seeking to help
people's lives
uh incredibly um prolific person
especially
uh such a young age to be doing what
he's doing for for so long now
so i hope you enjoyed this episode of
the impossible podcast with evan
carmichael
a little bit of a change but i think
you'll get a lot out of this episode
please
remember as they say to like comment
subscribe
review post i don't know do whatever you
have to do
so that we get more attention for the
podcast on itunes and on youtube
thank you so much enjoy today's episode
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic
[Music]
let's get started today today my guest
is none other than the uh
uh effervescent unbelievable uh
evan carmichael uh i'm working on all
these you know s.a.t words that we can
work words i like it you can actually
make most of those from your name your
name is so long that it has uh
uh so many different uh so many
different aspects of it
good for scrabble i guess that's right
yeah i wonder what the
bonus bonus score would be for that uh
so
i've been really fascinated by you and i
first want to have a shout out to my
friend although i've never met i've
talked to people that she's recommended
and uh and uh proffered to me but i've
never met her talk to her and that's
rina friedman
watts uh watts friedman who's a
podcaster in her own right she's the
proprietors of the better call daddy
uh podcast wonderful podcast thank you
so much reena for connecting with evan
evan you are many things and i want to
try to understand a little bit of how
you get so much done
and i assume you have the same amount of
time as as i do which is 24 hours
although in canada
you know anything goes right you might
have more time we've legislated more
time here north of the border
that's right goes more slowly i probably
have less time because i uh
i did a sleep study test and uh i was
really hoping it was like
i wasn't sleeping very well i woke up
tired and uh
i was trying to find some hack and i
went to do a sleep test and he said
there's no hack you just need to sleep
eight and a half to nine hours
you don't get enough oxygen in your
system while you're sleeping
and it's not it's not severe enough to
get the cpap machine although if you
want one we can you can get you on one
but basically you just need to sleep
eight and a half to nine hours a night
and i was going in hoping okay
how do i get down to six and still feel
super energetic so yeah we all have the
same 24 hours but
i need to sleep eight and a half to nine
to function properly i always say i get
up at five
at the crack of five every day i go to
the bathroom and go back to sleep for
another eight hours so
that's my secret uh we all have our have
our discipline you might want to get one
of these rings i got one of these rings
here this is an
ura ring that actually tracks your sleep
tracks your resting heart rate your
heart rate variability all sorts i don't
know how techy you are i assume
i love i love tracking what do you do
with the data
like how has it actually made you a
better sleeper so it doesn't make
necessarily make me a better sleeper
although it will kind of like
i was joking with my wife i'm like it
stresses me out to think about like
lowering my stress
uh with this sleep thing but uh what it
will do i'm a pilot in my uh as a hobby
and if i get like a really bad sleep
score and it's bull you know it's from
zero to a hundred i've never gotten
above an 80 something i've got a bunch
of young kids at home by the way
uh but uh uh but if it's really low i
won't i won't fly i will say this is not
it's not it just doesn't make sense for
me to fly i'll postpone it luckily i
don't have to get anywhere nowadays with
any
alacrity whatsoever but i would use it
as a post-optimization metric rather
than kind of
pre-gaming how i'm going to sleep i
think the only way to do it there's
i have had guests on dr judson brewer
and others
um you know meditation there's lots of
ways to help you with that this ring
won't do that it's like monitoring your
calories or something which is
another topic i want to talk to you
about
so i mean i love data i've got i've got
a fitbit on me right now my goal is 20
000 i'm at 14 000 jumps
i'm on a trampoline all day long so yeah
yeah that's good
i love data i just struggled with any of
the sleep tracking stuff
i like i like that that's a good idea i
mean for me
there really is i guess there's always
an option right if i
if i scored a 14 on the sleep score do i
cancel all of my appointments today i
mean maybe i'm sure everybody would
understand and say hey brian sorry man
we got to wait till next time i think
i'm sure people would understand uh but
i
i'm more i mean it makes sense like hey
if your kids
were really noisy last night that
destroys your sleep score so i'm going
to tell them
you'll be quiet or try to figure
something else out right or have someone
else drive them to school right it's the
input like how do i change the input
to get a better sleep that i that that
that i can't feel right i mean if i stay
up really late i know i'm gonna get a
crappy sleep score
if i drink coffee at 10 o'clock at night
i know i'm not going to sleep very well
i don't need a ring to tell me that
so that's where i really struggle is i
want i badly want
to get data to make me optimize
everything and sleep is super important
i don't know how to use the data that
tells me i got a crappy sleep score how
to make that
better right yeah so for me again it's
it's really looking at it in terms of
like
risk analysis and then in the upcoming
day rather than i mean you can use it
there are
tick you know kind of people that do you
know if you see patterns over time you
know it's like you don't wait for the
the heart attack to say oh i i shouldn't
have gone you know had that a
eighth cheeseburger yesterday you know
you don't you don't wait for it so it's
kind of like looking at trends over time
and you'll see look maybe you'll see
when you need more vacation i mean you
work
non-stop i've heard about your schedule
you do certain things on certain days
maybe that's not right maybe you
shouldn't do all your youtube stuff on
tuesdays
you know maybe you should like maybe
you'll tweak it up maybe you know
fridays is a better day because you have
a weekend to recover
i don't know um i feel like it's like
you know if i'm asking you for advice
about cosmology
and the origin of the universe like i
feel like i should be asking you these
questions about
it what do you think we're setting up
for today brian i got nothing on that
no but i did want to talk about weight
loss and and talk about all sorts of
other things but first i want to
kind of introduce you for my audience
might you know is usually used to seeing
scientists and
and leader you know peak performers and
kind of billionaires and
and sort of interesting people in
different spaces academic freedom
i just talked to another canadian uh by
the name of god sad today he's a
popular podcaster on youtube as well um
not not quite at the
he's he's one order of magnitude below
you and then i'm like
five orders of magnitude below him so
you can kind of do the math and where
i'm at but uh but i do want to talk
about that for
for my audience as well uh because i'm
fascinated by people that
that have a mission statement that have
a vision
a lot of us have a strategy where we
want to be at the end of our life but
how do you get there is all based on
other tactics that you employ on a
regular basis so
i find fascinating about you in addition
to your
i think i've counted eight youtube
channels uh that you're the proprietor
of in one way or another
uh main channels success channel
entrepreneur channels
um you have a channel for black
excellence the best of gary vee
just again on and on and on it's
incredibly impressive but you're the
author
of two books and i really want to talk
about those books i don't usually ask
the authors to
recapitulate the whole book because i
want you to have massive book sales and
i
i don't like it when i was giving a talk
about my book losing the nobel prize and
people are saying but tell us the entire
thesis of your book and exactly what's
on every
you know no i want to sell some books
actually
uh but and i want to sell your book but
i want to understand
how you came to this mission you've got
on your shirt so i'm a pilot i told you
that already um
if i was going to choose an emblem to
that exemplifies the wonder the majesty
the the hopefulness of the four forces
of flight
that allow a plane to stay aloft i would
not
choose a tenuous tendril of an aircraft
such as a paper airplane i would choose
my spirit animal my spirit airplane is
the a-10 warthog
it's ugly it's it's huge it's bulky it
carries tons of weapons and it likes to
get down and dirty
why choose a paper airplane got it
that's a great question so
so my logo is a is a gold paper airplane
and i did it because that to me
represents entrepreneurship
so we want entrepreneurs we want to go
further we want to get out of where we
are now we want to build something we
want to explore we want to
we want to fly that's what we want to do
but we don't have money
you know at the beginning nobody's got
money you don't have the resources you
probably don't have the connections i
mean if you do bless you but most people
you're setting up with nothing and you
didn't go to school for it and you know
so
you you but you've got the tenacity
you've got the will you've got the hard
work you got the drive so to me that's a
paper airplane
it's not a jet or it's not your favorite
airplane like that costs a lot how much
does your
your thing cost you can't buy the uh a10
warthog
yeah but it's military but yeah if you
wanted to 20 million
20 million yeah perfect great like
nobody's got 20 million dollars to start
a business
but you got a piece of paper so start
and i love the idea of like we're we're
we're battling the elements and our
the the edges are getting torn and
tattered and bruised but we still fly
and if you watch the videos when we
first did
that airplane and we animated it my
editor added this
airplane noise to it and it sounded like
this crop duster kind of coming across
the screen
i'm like it doesn't feel big enough you
know like
sure a paper airplane sounded like a
crop duster i guess is big for a paper
airplane
because there's no engine on a paper
airplane but i want it to be a jet
and i wanted to break the sound barrier
so the airplane flies across the screen
and then you hear the sonic boom of it
breaking a sound barrier
and and for a paper airplane to do that
i think that's what entrepreneurs do
every day
so that's that's the story behind the
paper airplane
now why why should anyone want to be an
entrepreneur i mean it's fraught with
legal challenges
financial challenges stress the the
whole burden is on you
taxes regulations uh i take my hat off
to you i i work in an industry the
professorship industry
i don't have to make i lose money on
every sale so to speak
my my my uh production is only to make
academic research papers maybe do some
outreach speaking communicating to the
public
and which i love teaching to my students
i don't i don't
have you know responsibilities of the
crushing weight of
employees hr taxes regulations like i
said
why should anyone want to do it it's so
risky and as you said
you start off it's almost infinite
downside and
very low chance of upside why do it
uh i think it's just a perspective you
know i i think the same thing of like
why should i be
why should i go to school what's the
point of going to university
some of the people behind you didn't
some of the people right behind your
shoulder did not go to university or
drop shipping and it's just a
perspective shift like you found the
career path that works really well for
what you love
and and allows you to do your work and
write books and inspire
students and but there's a lot of like
if i stepped into your life
i would i would hate myself in like
eight minutes
just because i'm i don't want to do what
you're doing and vice versa
so what what you see is all these
problems i see is yeah okay
and like it's nothing compared to the
impact they get to have and the business
i get to build and the life i get to
create for myself and the
team i get to hire i get to pick who
works with me and i get to have
whatever 360 million views around the
world the people who i'm inspiring right
so i see all the positive just like if i
would look at your career i just see all
the things that i would never want to do
i don't want to have to i don't have to
deal with a boss i don't want to have to
deal with university timelines i don't
but you're saying oh that stuff doesn't
i mean sure it's there but
all these positives i get to do all the
right so i think
it's just a self-awareness thing and
it's i think it's amazing that not
everybody
we just like package kids up and they
can only do one thing and that's it
forever i think
that's part of the journey of becoming
an adult human
and especially now in a 2020 2021
environment
the choice is available to us our
parents didn't have
you know i'm 40 right now the the the
opportunities available to my parents at
40
it's crazy the fact that we'd be having
this conversation like this wouldn't
exist to my parents
so there's so many more opportunities to
pick the path that you want to go off
and do and it's never been more
easy to accomplish i think everybody
should try everything at the beginning
micro dose on it and just see right like
how do you know if you like sushi
until you try it i did i don't well
listen sushi sounds disgusting you're
gonna take
raw fish and wrap it in seaweed
with some rice dip it in some crazy hot
mustard
and and you're gonna pay for that right
i mean it sounds
nasty now you don't like it but a lot of
people do i like sushi
but but on paper it doesn't look like
you would actually like it so i think
people should try it
uh i think people should try
entrepreneurship i think people should
try youtube i think
people should try to write i think
people should try to be a good student
like i think you should try these things
and then see what you gravitate towards
whether you don't even have to be good
at it
it's just do you like it because if you
like writing
but you suck at it and you're making
spelling mistakes and all of this stuff
and you might have people around you
telling you that you'll never be a
writer but if you just
like it and you keep doing it
you'll get great at it and so i think
people need to try more things
yeah i i absolutely agree i mean you
don't know what's going to blossom in
the field until you water it and give it
fertilizer and i think
that's a lesson people overlook because
they're so
scared of failure you know we talk about
you know fear of success
fomo fear of missing out there's a lot
of fear in academia
you know you have all these gatekeepers
i talked with our mutual friend james
altitude about this
uh earlier this year and how you know
his whole thesis is
choosing yourself and in your case it's
all about believing
and i wonder uh when you when when i
think about belief
i i think i don't i don't actually
believe in gravity
like i don't believe in the law of
evolution i've got evidence for it
so so you know i i know that it takes
place because we have
evidence for it and so scientists don't
believe things as
as people may be of faith and i'm not
denigrating religion at all
uh my listeners know that but uh but
things that you have to believe in
are necessarily those things for which
we don't have evidence so
what on what basis you you did your
interview with james last year
and you said you met someone and he said
something like you're the only person
who ever believed in me you evan
carmichael and you never met this guy so
what is it about belief that is so
empowering to the person who is believed
in i think it's the world's biggest
problem
i think i think everybody i start with
the premise that everybody's got michael
jordan level genie and said something
like you're the best in the world that's
something but you don't
you don't believe that you are and just
to the thing about evidence
i would i would push back on that you
know i did
a interview with james right
so mutual fund we went to his new york
comedy club we did he asked me to come
on a show when
lights and cameras and um you know i had
known him for a while but that was i
think our first time ever
like meeting in the same room great so
it went fantastic
i taught him when he had a merengue
dance uh with my wife
we had a great time great show did super
well
he was then gonna come on my instagram
to do uh
instagram live together and before that
happened
i was a little nervous my heart's
beating is like i don't want to i don't
want to disappoint james
we're not actually afraid of failing
we're afraid of failing in front of
people
we're afraid of failing and who sees us
we'll sing in the shower but we won't
sing on the street corner
because you're afraid of the the
judgment of you failing not the actual
failure
so i'm getting a little nervous before
going live with james why
i i know james he's not a super close
homie but you know
we we've done videos already all the
evidence tells me that
everything will go super well and yet i
still have the doubt
that's the lack of belief so evidence is
great i love it
but it's not enough because we're not
just rational creatures
we're emotional and it's that emotion
that prevents us from
taking the action if we just did
everything rationally we'd we take
shots on things a lot more but it's our
fear of disappointing others and our
fear
of failing in front of other people that
prevents us from actually taking action
that we need to
so that's why i think belief is at the
core when you
believe in the ability to go off and
create something whether this one thing
maybe this show the one thing that you
do doesn't work but the next thing and
the next thing
the next thing the belief that it's
possible or the hope that you could be
in a better spot than you are right now
without that belief that you can change
your life
you don't change your life despite all
the evidence being
otherwise there's lots of people who
came from where you're at with less than
what you've got
and they went off and crushed it and
you're not because of the story you told
yourself
not just because of the evidence so i
think it's both it's not just like black
and white
evidence that's it um we make emotional
decisions and so you have to
tap into those emotions to serve you
instead of hold you back i know you've
described yourself as an introvert and
uh that doesn't seem to have hampered
you i know a lot of successful people
are actually introverted there's an old
joke about you know a scientist how do
you know a scientist
is not an introvert well it's when he
looks at your shoes when he talks to you
instead of his own
and but i look at you and i think like
you've succeeded in this realm like
eventually
there has to come a level where you're
not going to be as as
uh suspicious or worried about your
traits like we say in science
we say the um you know the plural of
anecdotes
is not data in other words just because
you have a whole bunch of personal
experience doesn't count as
evidence but it sounds like and i agree
with you
in the personal realm there should come
a time like
you know like are you nervous that your
wife doesn't really love you i mean
you're you got like after a certain
amount of time what
is it still true that you'll feel this
this nagging insecurity
after everything i mean you've
accomplished more than you know the top
you know 100th of a percent of people in
your field you're you're
a success you know and the thought
leader in your field
how could is is that is that just never
going to leave you i mean if it's
in other words if you don't feel that
you've reached this level of
self-confidence what hope is there for
schlub
like me uh this is a great quote that i
like which says beyond the mountain
is more mountains yeah you're never done
climbing you don't want to hit the top
of the mountain
because then you hate your life as
humans you want to grow and continue to
learn
like i think if you don't have anything
in your calendar that get
pumps your heart a little bit with with
nerves and anxiety or excitement
whatever you want to call it
if you don't have anything in your
calendar for the next month that does
that to you
i think you hate your life i think
you're just photocopying the same day
over and over and over and over and over
again
and so sure uh getting on
if i was to do this 10 years ago i would
i would be freaking out i want to know
every question you're going to ask me
you know i want to have it all laid out
because i'd be worried about
disappointing you about not being a good
guest on your show
um that's much less of a worry right now
because i've done
i don't know how many how many shows but
but it's still
i don't want to i don't want to show up
late i don't want to
i don't want to not have good answers
you know for you it's still a concern
um but less so and now i'm capable of
doing
bigger things i'm capable of going on
a stage with 2 000 people uh and that's
the thing that freaks me out or
or this today i had a instagram live
with a
woman who wrote a new book and she's got
four and a half million
followers on instagram and i don't know
i've never heard of her before
and now i have to interview her about
her book so i'm researching her and my
heart's beating like oh my gosh i hope i
don't ask
a stupid question or the wrong question
or whatever right it's not paralyzing
i think that's the point it's like
teaching yourself to lean in on those
moments
if you're worried if your heart's
beating if you've got an idea
to write a book to start a show to
interview somebody to
whatever and your heart's beating i
think that means it's go time where
we've been trained to say
let's play small let's not do it let's
back down that's too scary
it's it's not physically scary right
like
don't jump from a plane with no
parachute
that's scary but it's stupid right most
of the things that we're not doing is
because of again the fear of rejection
or the fear of
how people see us and that is like
teaching yourself that's not a good
enough reason not to act
yeah yeah i mean that's resonates with
something else james always
lives by a rule that if he's not scared
to hit the publish button he won't write
that he won't submit the article he has
to be scared about it and he's gotten
into some trouble
but you know he's an incredibly
courageous person you have a few more
minutes evan i don't i want to be
mindful of your time
uh yeah we got we got we got i got four
more minutes okay good
all right so first i want to say a
famous quote by galileo galilei who's
the first astronomer to ever use a
telescope he says
make measurable what is not measurable
and
and measure what is measurable so i want
to ask you as a leader
or as a podcast how do you know you're
doing a good job it can't just be
views and thumbs up i mean those are
meaningless in some sense
how do you know evan carmichael at the
end of the day when you do your
inventory your accounting of your day
your soul how do you know you did a good
job
i think how you feel about yourself when
you're by yourself
is the game to play and so
i have a thing at night that i call the
pillow test which is before i hit my
head on the pillow
am i proud of the effort that i put in
today the effort
not the result because the results can
can vary a lot during the day right if
if you tie yourself worth to getting
results
then you're only going to one do things
that you know you're going to get a
result in
and so you therefore you play small for
life and you only have these little
small moments of when you get a result
so it's much more about the effort did i
play full out today am i proud of what i
did today
uh and that's that's ongoing so today
you know so we're recording this on a
thursday
and thursday is my public facing day
where i'm doing interviews and podcasts
um you know the whole day and did i did
i show up did i
did i try to answer the question did i
you know am i sitting i wish
i said this to brian when he asked me
that question i wish i knew that
airplane or
you know like whatever it is are you
proud of the effort that you put in
today
because if you're constantly proud of
the effort the results will happen
they will come if you're putting in your
max effort you may not
be happy with the result for the day if
you have a a writing count for your book
and you want to get a 500 words done
today you might write 500 words that are
crap and not be happy with it the result
isn't there but you did the 500 words
and i i pat myself on the back for doing
the 500 words
and hopefully that leads to like if i
did that every day not every day is
going to be great
but i will ultimately create great
things
all right the final question i usually
ask a bunch of questions to close out
the show
but uh i'll just ask the the main one
that i'm most interested to hear from
you
and it comes from the name of this
podcast this is called the into the
impossible podcast
and those uh three words are my three
words and they come from sir arthur
three clark's so-called third law
and he said the only way of discovering
the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
in other words when you were 20 30 years
old what thing seemed
literally impossible to you not like
we'd have a phone in our pocket but to
you evan carmichael
but you had the courage you had the
discipline you had the ethic and
integrity
and because of those traits of yours you
were able to do the impossible
yeah even this like go back
10 years when i just started my youtube
channel 11 years ago i was super shy
introverted afraid of being on camera i
i wouldn't be on a show like this and
why i'm trying to lean into like the
introvert and all that kind of stuff is
to say that i'm not
i'm i'm i'm a normal like i'm just a
normal guy
you know a lot of your audience is
probably already better at some of the
things that i do
than than i was when i started and i
think
everybody listening think about who you
were
10 years ago or five years ago
what you're doing right now seems like
an impossibility to
the person you used to be already like
you are
everybody listening you've done some
things if you've grown at all over the
last 10 years
10-year younger version of you what
you're doing now they would see is
that's not possible
and and that has actually
wrapped up everybody's purpose like your
purpose is to show
10 years younger you of what is
actually possible yeah because there's
there's millions of people right now
who currently are 10 years younger
version of you
and they have no hope when they don't
feel like things are possible
so you can guide them you can be a you
could be their spirit animal you can
show them that the path
is possible when when uh when a brian or
an evan
you may not listen to us but they'll
listen to you because you've been
through what they're going through
that's right well evan carmichael i want
to thank you so much for what you do
everything you did you do for both me
personally we've never met but you've
had a great impact
uh on a lot of different aspects of my
life i certainly know that's true of
millions of people around the world
keep up the great work uh be blessed in
everything you do
and i just want to thank you so much
author of your one word and the latest
built to serve
evan carmichael thank you so much
appreciate your man thanks for the fun
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
[Music]
magic
[Music]
[Music]
you